well I might quit acting I want to work
with those guys they're so cool um but
instead let's do more color stuff um
open color io is an open source
framework that enables consistent color
of motion pictures across multiple
facilities and software applications
developed at sony pictures imageworks in
2003 open color io works with other
color management systems to provide a
full color pipeline open color io can be
downloaded from the web it also provides
a complete set of building blocks that
allows users to create custom color
management profiles from their workflows
these color profiles can be rolled out
into entire facility's nice everybody
loves free software right yep open
collar io represents the culmination of
years of production experience earned on
such films as spider-man 2 and many many
more for the development for the
development of open color io color
management framework the academy
presents Jeremy salon and with the
technical of the tentacle Achievement
Award apologize thank you there's no
possible way I can one-up Josh Pines
here so I'm just going to keep it simple
I'd like to thank everyone who has
contributed to open color I oh thanks to
rob Bray dough for making this open
source project possible it really
wouldn't have happened without him
thanks to Malcolm Humphries been Dixon
and the rest of our open source
developer community also a big thanks to
image works artists and its technical
leadership both past and present now to
get serious for a moment back in
nineteen hundred Lord Kelvin famously
predicted that there is nothing new left
to be discovered in physics yet what
followed was one of the richest
centuries of discovery in history this
is true now it's all too easy to look at
our industry today in visual effects and
animation and be similarly pessimistic
because of economic challenges and
maturing tool sets many of the brightest
minds tonight even have left for other
fields however I suggest that there's
really something special about digital
motion-picture technology our industry
and I really believe this is one of the
rare exam
polls where moore's law directly
advances creative potential and as such
no one can predict the future for this
industry and considering that our paint
brushes to use an analogy get ten times
more powerful every decade we certainly
still have reason to be optimistic so
thank you